Speaker 1: Super interesting new polling out
of Florida that I want to talk about, and
it's looking better and better for Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis, and it's looking worse
and worse for the former President Donald
Trump.
When we look at Florida favorability, Trump
is way down and DeSantis is doing very well,
and this is relevant for a few different reasons
which we're going to talk about.
But top level, when we look at the Republican
field for 2024, right now, there's really
two names being mentioned it's Donald Trump
and Ron DeSantis.
And of course, there's all of these other
discussions about what about Republicans going
back to someone like a Mitt Romney who I don't
think is even remotely interested in it or
whatever else.
Those are all perfectly reasonable discussions.
Are some people saying, What about Don Jr.,
which I think is idiotic but plausible given
the Republican electorate or whatever else?
But right now, we're talking about Trump,
DeSantis, and that's exactly why Florida is
so important.
So let's take a look at the numbers.
A new poll has Biden losing to disband to
send Trump in Florida, but that's not super
interesting to me right now that that's going
to be impacted much more by what Biden does.
New poll This is USA Today new poll says Joe
Biden is struggling in Florida, where more
than half of potential voters disapprove of
his handling of the economy and of his job
overall.
Suffolk University USA Today Network poll
of likely Florida voters suggests only 39
percent approve of Joe Biden's job.
53 percent disapprove.
While President Trump won Florida in 2020,
Biden and the Democrats hope to make a big
play for the nation's third most populous
state, one that will have 30 electoral votes
in 2024.
The new poll indicates their work is cut out
for them.
The most important numbers here are, and I
am trying to find them.
Where exactly are they?
The new poll are DeSantis, the first term
governor leads.
Oh no, this is the Florida.
So let's let's actually get to the right data,
OK?
Most Republicans, many Republicans see to
scientists as a potential presidential candidate
in 2004.
But the new poll has him losing a Republican
primary 47 40 to Donald Trump.
The poll has both Trump and DeSantis defeating
Biden or Clinton in a general election matchup
in Florida.
DeSantis leads Biden 52 44.
Trump's margin over Biden is closer 47 44.
So DeSantis is doing better than Trump against
Biden in the state of Florida.
DeSantis has not publicly disclosed a run.
And of course, anything could change, and
it's very, very early now.
It's easy to write this off and say, David,
this is just a Florida poll.
This is not a national poll.
And DeSantis is the governor of Florida.
Of course, he's going to do well, but that's
exactly why it matters, because it's Florida
and because Florida is likely to be so important
in upcoming elections.
Now, there's so much still to happen, including
the 2022 midterms before we get into any even
remotely specific conversation about 2024.
But there's a very clear trend when you look
at all of the CPAC straw polls that we've
recently seen of Republican favorability polls,
open ended questions about who would you like
to see run?
The trends are as follows.
Trump favorability has been declining.
Percentage of Republicans who want Trump to
run in 24 has been declining.
It's now barely over half of Republicans,
as we talked about earlier this week, want
Trump to run in 2024.
And when we talk about who other than Trump
is being mentioned, the only person with any
remotely significant level of support is Ron
DeSantis.
This is another reason why I should mention
Ron DeSantis.
His reelection campaign going on right now
is so important.
Could Ron DeSantis lose reelection in November
and still run in 2024 successfully?
Yes, he could.
He could.
But it is much more likely that Republican
voters would support the guy who won reelection
in 2002 than the guy who lost it.
And this just has to do with the idea of,
you know, supporting a loser for some bigger
office when they lost their last election.
Has it happened?
Of course it has.
But this is another reason why if we could
knock out DeSantis, it would make it an even
bigger uphill battle for him in 2004.
And the reason why I say that you might be
saying, Well, but David, what do you want
Trump?
No.
The issue is DeSantis is a less incompetent,
but just this dangerous version of Trump in
my mind.
And the fact that he's less cartoonish but
has the same disastrous political instincts
in my mind would make him more effective at
being able to destroy the country.
So I see DeSantis as more dangerous than Trump
for that reason.
We're going to continue following the numbers,
and we're going to continue following the
Republican Civil
War speech,